So here's one way to define hashtable_lookup. So we're going to take
the table and the key. And the first step is to
find the bucket, so we'll use the hashtable_get_bucket that we defined
earlier for that, and store it in a variable called bucket.
So we'll use hashtable_get_bucket to look up in the hashtable where
that key would occur, and we'll store that in the bucket.
But now to do the lookup we need to go through
all the entries in that bucket, find one that matches the key.
To do the lookup, we need to go through all the
entries in the bucket. So we'll use a for loop for that,
going through the entries. For each entry, we need to check whether
the key part of that entry, matches the key, and remember the
bucket was a list of entries. And each entry in the bucket
was a keyword in the value. In the case for our web
crawler, the value was a list of URLs. So if the entry
matches the key, so the first part of the entry is the
keyword, if that matches the key we're looking for, then what
we want to do is return the value. So that's the result
of entry position one. If it doesn't match, well then we
want to keep going, keep trying the next, we're going to keep going through
this for loop, checking all the entries in the bucket. When
we get to the end, we didn't find it, and what
we said in the question was if it's not in the
table, what we should do is output none, so now we'll return,
the value none. So let's try that in the Python interpreter.
So here's the code, we're defining a hashtable_lookup, we find the bucket,
we loop through all the entries in the bucket, if we
find one where the key matches, we return the value associated with
that key, otherwise we return none. When we got to the
end of the bucket without finding the entry, we know it couldn't
exist anywhere else in the hash table because the only place that
keyword could appear is in this bucket. We still have all the
same code from before, that makes the hashtable, that gets the
bucket and then adds to the table. And, we'll test it
using some of the code we wrote before. We're going to add
several words to our hashtable, and let's try looking up a
keyword. We'll look up udacity. And we get the value 23,
which is what we expect, that's the value that we associated
with udacity. So this is looking pretty good. We've got our
hashtable almost working. The one problem is the one we mentioned
before, if we try to change the value
associated with udacity, and we're going to need to
do this for our web index, right? When we add all of the urls to the table,
we need to keep adding UR, URLs. We don't want to lose the one we have, but we
want to change the value associated with, with that
keyword. Now, we do the look up again, and
we get the same result. And the reason we got the
same result, if we look at the bucket in the hashtable that's
associated with the keyword udacity, well what we see is it's a
list of two elements. And because of the way we implemeneted add,
the newer one is later in that list, because of the way
we define lookup, it's always going to find the first one it matches.
It's going through the entries in order. The first one that matches
it returns that value. So thats why we get the value 23.
So we're really almost done, but we have to
make one other change. We want to change add to be
more like update. So instead of adding a new entry,
we want to update the value that's associated with that entry.